>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
[ Silence ]
>> Georgette Dorn: Good afternoon.
My name is Georgette Dorn and I'm
the head of the Hispanic Division
of the Library of Congress.
It is very, very nice to
welcome everybody to the library
which the home of the biggest
Latin American collection
in the world actually.
We have 170 million items of
which 14 million pertain to Spain
and Latin America in
the Iberian world.
We also are the home of
[inaudible] Latin American studies
which is an online and in print
bibliography published here
since 1936.
Also the home of the
[inaudible] tape
where we have 750 recorded
authors since 1943.
And as of two years ago we have
100 of them online available
on the Hispanic Division's webpage.
It is my pleasure to
welcome Dr. Michael Francis.
He received his Ph.D.
in history in 1998
from the University of Cambridge.
Between 1997 and 2012 he taught at
the University of North Florida.
In '12 Dr. Francis was
named the Hough Family Chair
of Floridian studies
at the University
of South Florida in St. Petersburg.
In 2016 he was appointed Chair
of the Department of History
and Politics at University of
South Florida, St. Petersburg.
Dr. Francis has received
more than two dozen national,
international awards including
a four year appointment
as research fellow of the American
Museum of Natural History, New York
and the J. Kislak fellowship
at the Library
of Congress in Washington, DC.
He served on the St. Augustine
450th commemoration commission
and is curator of the traveling
museum exhibit, Imagining La Florida
on Ponce de Leon and the Quest
for the Fountain of Youth.
Dr. Francis has written
and edited five books
and numerous book chapters
and articles.
His most recent book
published in 2015 is entitled,
St. Augustine, America's First City.
With us, Dr. Francis.
[ Audience Applause ]
>> J. Michael Francis: Thanks
so much Georgette and thank you
for coming on a beautiful day.
Walking over here and I thought
it's a gorgeous spring day.
Everyone's going to
want to be outside.
So we're going to do this indoors.
The last time I was here I think the
discussion, the talk was really all
about anniversaries
and commemoration,
historical commemorations because
Florida went through a series
of these commemoration moments
really almost consistently
since 2013.
There was one commemoration
after another.
And so today I'm going to
talk about a new project.
A project that we've been working on
at the University of South Florida,
St. Petersburg and with partners
in Spain and in other places
in the United States that
I'd like to share with you.
So thank you to the Hispanic
Division, to [inaudible]
and Georgette for inviting me
here today and for the University
of South Florida Foundation and
Julie Gillespie and Julie Perrelli.
I'd really like to thank and
point out this is a project
that historical research is
often a rather solitary affair.
We like to sit in archives
by ourselves
in quiet doing our research.
And this is really a project
that from the very beginning has
been a collaborative endeavor.
It's a project that has really
brought in a team of scholars
from different disciplines,
different institutions
and of course it's a way.
It has been a project that
I've had wonderful success
with some phenomenal graduate
students at the University
of South Florida who are
working on this project with me,
Rachael Sanderson, Hannah Tweet
and Trevor Bryant in particular.
But we have a whole team
of graduate students
who have been working on this.
As I said Florida has experienced
these commemoration moments
since 2013.
The first of course centered
around this individual.
What you see here is Juan
Ponce de Leon's signature.
And in Florida in 2013 commemorated
the 500 year anniversary
of something related related
to Juan Ponce de Leon.
It was still quite a
mystery as the year unfolded,
what is it that we're commemorating
and what exactly did he do
and why are we commemorating this?
And often the answer especially
in the political sphere
was well we need
to tell everybody that we're old.
That we're first.
They love first's and oldest
even when first aren't first's
and oldest are not oldest.
And so there was this
whole discussion.
I don't know if you
followed the debate,
sometimes a rather heated
debate that unfolded in Florida
over where did Ponce land?
And different communities fought.
There were newspaper articles,
battles back and forth
about where Ponce landed.
So I guess the real takeaway
in 2013 was no one
agreed where Ponce landed.
And he did something, we're old.
So that was the takeaway I suppose.
Two years later the City
of St. Augustine commemorated
its 450 year anniversary.
And of course you have
to have cake I guess
when you're celebrating
historical anniversaries.
This is the day of the
anniversary, September 8, 2015,
marked the 450 year commemoration.
What was striking about that
in a way when I reflect back
on that moment, the highest
ranking political official
to attend the 450th, the actual day,
the 450th was Florida's
Secretary of State.
So it still didn't I guess generate
a kind of national interest.
Now of course ten days later the
Royal Majesties of Spain arrived,
King Felipe VI and Queen Letizia.
And then lots of people came
to St. Augustine ten days
after the actual anniversary.
He's, this is King Felipe VI.
He's 6'6".
I'm getting there I
hope one day to be 6'6".
I'm standing behind him so
it makes me look shorter.
In any case they came and of course
that attracted a great
deal of interest.
And I remember speaking with the
city manager during that visit
and shortly thereafter and he
really posed this question.
Now that the anniversaries
have passed,
now that there's been national
and international attention.
The Royal Majesties
of Spain have come
to commemorate this
moment, where do we go?
What's next?
And sometimes it was a
little disheartening.
I remember reviewing a national
history textbook not long ago.
I won't mention the state.
It begins with M and
ends with chusetts.
But it was a national
history text that was going
out to junior high school
students around the country.
And one of the chapters was on
the colonization of North America.
And the chapter began
with Jamestown.
And I thought what
are we doing wrong?
The first people of African descent
in the textbook came
to Virginia in 1619.
So that's only off by 106 years
of the first recorded person
of African descent, Juan
Garrido who was part
of Ponce de Leon's 1513 expedition.
So maybe there's something we
can do a little bit differently.
And what we've, what we're
starting and what we'll launch
in the fall is a center, digital
center for colonial Florida history.
And it's really built on projects.
A whole series of projects that
preceded this one, that are working
at the same time as this one.
Of course the Spanish website Pares,
if you're not familiar
with this site.
It's an absolutely remarkable
website of documents and maps
from a number of almost a dozen
Spanish state archives, digitized.
There are millions of
documents, maps, images,
photographs from the
Spanish civil war,
documents from medieval Spain all
the way up to the 20th century.
And this is something that the
Spanish government's been doing
since the 1980s.
They were really a pioneer
in terms of digitization,
making this material available.
It's not the most user
friendly website.
Maybe that was a compromise.
We'll make the documents
available but it'll be so difficult
to navigate that nobody
will find the documents.
And it's pretty close.
It's a challenging one if you
have not used Pares in the past.
But of course it has
some remarkable,
remarkable documents in it.
Just some examples of some
the characters who lived
in colonial Florida who, about whom
you can research through Pares,
this is a letter written
to King Philip III.
It dates to the 20th
of February of 1600.
And it was written by this woman,
Dona Maria who was a Cacica,
Native American, a
Timucua Indian Chief.
One of numerous letters that Dona
Maria wrote to the King of Spain.
And there were responses.
She is a figure that outside
of St. Augustine is not
particularly well known.
My guess is if this letter were
signed Pocahontas the letter would
probably be in every textbook,
fourth grade textbook
in the country.
And yet we know quite
a bit about her.
Documents like a very small trove
of final wills and testaments.
We, it's rare to find
final wills from Florida.
There are only that we've been
able to locate, only about 40.
And there are reasons for that
that I'm happy to discuss later.
But the oldest one that we've
uncovered is a will from 1566,
one year after St. Augustine
was established in 1565.
Is that better?
There, okay, sorry.
And it's a will from a young
man named Bernard Jansen
who was from Bremen, Germany.
And poor, couldn't sign his name.
But it's a handful of wills
that will part of this center.
When we finish we'll publish all
of these wills with transcriptions
and translations of these
final wills from Florida.
And tales of people
like this individual,
whose real name was actually
Darby Glavin, he's Irish.
And the Spanish had no
patience with Darby as a name
so they just called
him David Glavid.
And David Glavid was,
has a fascinating story.
I mean, know about him in
the English historiography
that he was one of
the Roanoke settlers,
that Francis Drake took
him back to England.
He was sent back.
And somehow was captured by
the Spanish and was sentenced
to a life in the galleys.
That's the English
version of the narrative.
The Spanish story is
completely different.
David Glavid ends up
living in St. Augustine.
He testifies that he was a
fisherman off the coast of Ireland.
And the English kidnapped him.
Took him to Roanoke against
his will, stole his boat.
And he ended up at Roanoke,
went back to England with Drake.
And then Queen Elizabeth
II sent him back.
When he arrived in
Puerto Rico he ran away.
And he later joined the
Spanish, lived in St. Augustine.
He was a merchant and a
soldier in St. Augustine.
He was the guy you would
go to to get stuff.
If you wanted textiles
from Asia, you wanted some.
David Glavid was the merchant
who could acquire those goods.
Or somebody like Luisa Menendez.
We know lots of stories like
this from Mexico and Peru.
As a young girl she was
taken captive by the Spanish.
She was probably at the time
between the age of eight and ten.
She ended up living in
a Spanish settlement
in Florida called Santa Elena.
We call today Paris
Island, South Carolina.
And she was a domestic servant
in the home of St. Augustine,
St. Augustine's founder's
wife, Dona Maria de Solis.
She then ends up marrying a Spanish
solider whose 20 years her senior.
And she lives certainly from
what we can document well
into the early 17th century.
Of course the AGI then contains
all kinds of information
about food stuffs and supplies that
went from Spain to Florida or Cuba
to Florida, other places
with those supplies.
This is simply an inventory of
food stuffs that went to Florida
with the Menendez 1565 expedition.
So there's all this
material available.
It's not material you would
really publish by themselves.
And what I'm going to frame
for you is the idea we have
for this digital center.
For us it really began with a
project that I did with a couple
of graduate students at the
University of North Florida and then
at the University of South Florida
to digitize the parish records
in St. Augustine, Florida.
And these records date back to 1594.
They're the some of
the oldest documents
in the United States
about the United States.
And they're parish
records, baptisms, deaths,
confirmations, marriages.
And we started a project
to digitize 6,000 pages
of the colonial parish records.
And this was the team.
We did it for, I think our
budget was something like $5,500.
And we digitized all
of these documents
which are now available online.
You can see on the left
that's Jane Landers
from Vanderbilt University
who's written extensively
about Africans in Florida.
And then my two graduate
students on the far right
and Jane's team in between.
And this is what some of
these records look like.
This is one of the early
marriage records from 1594.
We do have the first
recorded baptism
of anybody of African descent.
And this was a record from 1595.
All right, this should be
much more readily available
to a broader audience
than it has been.
And that's part of the idea.
And of course some of
them look like this.
So desperate need of restoration
some of these documents.
They were shrink wrapped in
the 1920s, the early records
which is not good for
long term preservation.
But that's what they look like.
Now of course we've done
this and we've put them up.
And one of the things I constantly
hear from teachers is well wonderful
that you did that but how
are we supposed to use this?
How is it going to
be more accessible?
How are people who
maybe don't know much
about that early Florida history,
how are they going to use this?
And it makes perfect sense.
This is just a two line passage
that appears on the very front page
of a 17th century book of baptisms
within those parish records.
Now the handwriting
is not 17th century.
And before it was shrink
wrapped somebody
in his infinite wisdom
took a black marker
and wrote the year 1640 question
mark on the original document.
But the handwriting's
actually 18th century.
And when I first looked at
it, you know, the first word
that probably jumps out you
is the word diablo, devil.
I thought why is somebody writing
devil on the first opening page
of 17th century book of baptisms?
And the text reads
simply, my dear Lord,
not even the devil could read this.
The writing is so bad I can't
make out a single word in it.
So I teach Spanish, 16th century
Spanish paleography program
at the University South
Florida, St. Petersburg.
So when students come in the
first day I lock the door
and then I show them this.
And even those who think it's
paleontology then get really scared.
And when they realize
no, it's paleography.
We're going to learn how to read
16th century Spanish handwriting.
And I say not even, I say look,
bear with me for eight months
and you will learn a skill that
the devil himself does not possess.
And then they get excited.
Say all right, I'll stick
with this Spanish paleography
for the eight months.
And some do it for
two or three years
and become really quite
accomplished paleographers
for 16th century Spanish.
The projects we're going
to launch in the fall,
really the most important project
at least in terms of the amount
of work we put into it so
far is the prosopography.
And if that word or that term's
not familiar just think of it
in terms of collective biography.
If you were to ask for example,
take the [inaudible] expedition,
if you were to ask well what could
you say about the typical profile
of one of the conquistador's
Soto expedition?
What do we know about
where they were from?
Their ages?
Marital status?
Previous military experience?
Have they been in the Indies before?
Do they come from certain
parts or are they concentrated
in certain parts of Spain?
In other words the study of figures
about whom we don't know
a great deal and many
of them did not leave
written records.
So for the last oh I guess seven
or eight years I've been collecting
data on every single person I come
across who lived in Florida
between 1513 and 1821.
Yes, that's as exciting as my social
life is to be keeping this database.
And the database now has well
over 10,000 people in it.
In the next five years we
hope to double that number,
have more than 20,000
people in that database.
And then some of the other
projects I'll outline quickly
for you as I go through.
We do hope to bring in as
many institutional partners
as we can with this project.
And of course my interest really is,
although all of these are important,
the research opportunities I think
that this will bring for students
and for other faculty I
think is quite exceptional.
And then of course this
collaborative endeavor,
the nature of this.
And already we have some
partners, some important partners.
Many in Spain and some
here in the United States
and Francisco Gitard [assumed
spelling] is here from Madrid.
He works in Malaga for the
Institute Onelta [phonetic].
And all of the technological things
that we want to do I just drop
at his door and say make
this happen and he says okay.
We'll make that happen.
I started because I was intrigued
when Pedro Menendez
established St. Augustine in 1565
within the first three
years he and the captains
under his authority established
15 different garrisons
in the southeast.
You can see really from the visual
in fact one of his plans was
to establish a garrison in the
Chesapeake Bay area which failed.
But that was his ambition
to have garrisons that ran
up the Atlantic seaboard, a couple
of strategic points in the Gulf.
And then what his vision was was
to build a series of garrisons
into the interior that eventually
connected his deep water port
around Hilton Head,
present day Hilton Head,
South Carolina, with
Zacatecas, Mexico.
In other words the vision was
to move that silver overland
to a deep water port and
Pedro Menendez [inaudible]
of course would be
governor of this region.
A very ambitious plan,
obviously a plan that failed
for a number of reasons but failed.
And so within by 1570 there are
really only two garrisons left,
Paris Island, South Carolina,
the settlement at Santa Elena
and St. Augustine, Florida.
And St. Augustine after 1587,
St. Augustine's the
only one that survives.
It's the only one of these
early garrisons that survives
until the late 17th century when
the Spanish go back to Pensacola.
I was always interested in who were
the people who went to these places.
Who were the people who joined the
Menendez expedition after 50 years
of failed expeditions into Florida
beginning with Ponce de Leon?
One expedition after another
with the same outcome.
Menendez knows perfectly well there
isn't gold or silver or emeralds,
maybe some pearls in Florida.
So how's he able to recruit people?
And in particular for his expedition
he recruited over 2,000 individuals.
The expedition that followed him the
following year also included more
than 2,000 individuals.
These are two of the largest
expeditions to leave Spain
for any part of the
Indies in the 16th century
and they were expeditions
to Florida.
So we wanted to get a sense
of who these people were.
Especially when you look at the
kinds of professions that you see
in the manifest of professions
that Menendez recruited
for the expedition.
Twenty one tailors and ten
shoemakers, a couple of rope makers
and locksmiths and silversmiths,
a hat maker, 117 laborers.
And then this one's my favorite, at
one point I hope we find out exactly
who he was [inaudible], a master
beer brewer was on this expedition.
When you look at that
list those are the people
that in every single textbook
refers to as conquistadors.
Those are the conquistadors, the
hatmakers and shoemakers and tailors
and all of the professions
that in the end are required
for permanence, for settlement.
And so we wanted to
track those occupations
and who these people were and
what brought them to Florida.
So at present we have for the
Hernando de Sota expedition we have
about 845 people in
the database for that.
The Pedro Menendez de Aviles we
have almost 700 in that database.
The Sancho de Archiniega
expedition, this is an expedition
about which there's
almost nothing written.
A few references in the
secondary literature
but there's almost nothing published
on the Sancho de Archiniega
expedition.
That was the expedition with over
2,000 people on it from 1566.
And we've now found
almost all of them.
So that's the one we're going to use
to launch the center
site in the fall.
And then a couple of the settlements
and eventually we'll catch
up the Diasisin [phonetic]
records and be able to include all
of those Diasisin records
in this project.
So very briefly in terms
of the Sancho de Archiniega
at present we've identified 1833
people who went on that expedition.
We know the place of origin
for 84% of those people.
We know that at least
85 were non-Spaniards.
This number will probably
creep up to closer to 150
by the time I finish research in
Spain this summer because most
of mariners and the ship owners
and ship captains were Flemish
or Portuguese or German.
They're not Spanish.
So that number's going to
increase quite dramatically.
We will have a whole series of
infographics on this center site
where you can see a breakdown in
terms of the contemporary regions
where people were from and
be able to do this for all
of the expeditions to
see the differences
between the regional breakdowns.
Infographics like this where you can
see percentages of people who came
from Andalucia and, you know,
3% of the Archiniega expedition
was made up of Portuguese.
And the Portuguese are often
overlooked in the story.
Again these kind of infographics
where you can see different
regions and, you know,
who were the 12 Catalans?
And the 28 people from Valencia who
came on this expedition in 1566?
And just for students to be able
to see a contemporary map and see
that the breakdown of
individuals who participated
in this expedition included
Greeks, Northern Europeans, Flemish,
Italians, French, Portuguese,
North Africans.
One person from Florida who was a
native chief, we don't know much
about him, we don't
know where he was from.
But he was taken at some point.
Was baptized with the name
Pedro, was given honorific of Don
which was standard for
all Cacicas at the time.
And he was sent back to Spain
likely lived a life with Franciscans
or Jesuits, was taught Spanish.
And he went back on this
expedition to serve as a translator
and as a guide, breakdown
of the foreigners.
What was really striking when
we collected the data was
that when you look at the
makeup of this group they come
from 665 different places.
And this was surprising.
We thought we'd find
smaller networks of people
who were well connected
from childhood, who brought,
came together to establish
these companies.
And what we're finding is
something strikingly different
where almost 1/3rd
of them represented the only
individual from their town.
So it raises some really interesting
questions about these networks
and recruitment in Spain.
And now that we have the names and
where people were from we can start
to look at these questions
form the Iberian side,
from Spain and Portugal.
Greece is a little bit more
difficult but other places
and see what drew people to these
expeditions in the 16th century.
And what were these networks
that could quite quickly pull
together 2,000 individuals
to go on this expedition.
We know that most so
far come from Seville.
But what I can do now
with students who suffer
through the paleography program is
send a student for example to places
like Samota [phonetic] and
look through parish records
and notary records in Somota to
find out more about the individuals
that we've identified
from those locations.
This is something that keeps
me up at night and did,
and kept me up at night
when I was working on it.
I didn't include Fernandez,
now Fernandez
and Hernandez were used
interchangeably in the 16th century.
So if you add Hernandez and
Fernandez there are probably
about 105 people on the expedition
with the last name
Hernandez or Fernandez.
Many of them probably about
40 have the first name Juan.
So deciphering, trying to figure out
do I have the right Juan Hernandez
or when you see another one
in a document how do you know
which one Hernandez
or Fernandez that is?
And you see that, you know, we
have 52 Lopez's and 48 Martin's
and this will something that
will continue to be a challenge.
Occupations, we've identified
52 different occupations so far
of the people who came
on that expedition including
20 musicians and 7 priests.
We have the backgrounds
of some of the priests
who served on the expedition.
These six individuals in St.
Augustine were contracted
by the crown to service
professional fishermen.
That was their job.
They were paid a salary.
They were given a great big fishing
net and said your job is to fish
for the crown and that's
what you will do.
I don't know why you have a
Garcia Mendez from Cordoba.
Cordoba doesn't strike
me as the best place
to recruit a professional fisherman
but there he is, Garcia Mendez.
The barbers, those who performed
minor surgeries in addition
to tasks that barbers did.
We know the names of
those individuals
and where they were
from, the carpenters.
Literacy rate is very
difficult to track
for this expedition
but we're now at 11%.
We're getting closer.
It's still not statistically
meaningful the way we hope it will
be when we get closer to
30, 40, 50% literacy rates.
The image for 16th century Florida
in the secondary literature
is very much,
well this is a marginal
borderland of a borderland.
A place nobody really wanted to go
and certainly a place nobody
really wanted to stay.
And the people who went to
Florida were often kind of dregs
of Spanish society and they
said well you go to Florida.
It's lovely.
You know, they're working on Disney,
the beaches are perfect,
weather's nice.
And so the sense was that you
wouldn't find very many highly
educated individuals,
etc. What's emerging
from the prosopography is very
much a profile that's similar
to what we find elsewhere in the
Indies where you get this kind
of middling group of people,
semi-literate with a combination
of people who had a
formal university education
who stayed in Florida.
And then of course you look at ages.
And this is where things
get really interesting.
And this is where as a historian
and anybody who questions the nature
of written documents and how
should we read these documents?
When we first did the
numbers I realized wow,
the people who really colonized
Florida are my students.
And then I thought sometimes,
oh the people who colonized
Florida are my students.
And no, it's good.
I trust them.
The number, look at the highest
number here, 20 year old.
And of course one of the
mandates in the documents,
one of Archiniega's mandates
from the crown was you must
recruit 1,500 men, unmarried,
and you cannot recruit
anybody under the age of 20.
So I suspect that a number of these
people fall into the 19, 18, 17,
16 year old category and
are simply saying I'm 20.
Here's my ID.
And I'll show you what their ID
is because we have for Florida
about 400 physical
descriptions of people
from the 16th century
which is extraordinary.
When you think of how rare it
is to find physical descriptions
for people, we have
about 400 so far.
So you could be somebody like Pedro
[inaudible], tall, dark and handsome
with two scars on his
face and forehead.
And one of the things that
emerges out of these documents
in the 16th century is that
people were selling licenses
under the table as you might expect.
So Pedro [inaudible] might
stop in at a bar in Cordoba,
find somebody who looks
rather tall, dark and handsome
and say have a few drinks because
you're only missing a couple
of scars and then you can be me.
And lots of these licenses were
circulating under the table.
And people were coming to the
Americas as somebody else.
And so then poor Antonio Garcia that
shows up a little later and wants
to be tall, dark and handsome
gets to be round and fat
with a big nose, unfortunately
for him.
Francisco Marten [assumed spelling]
would have a difficult time selling
his license because he had
one eye and a scar next
to his left eye from a knife wound.
I expected to find a lot
more evidence of people
who had survived small pox.
And to date of all of the people
for whom we have physical
descriptions they're only five
that we've identified
who have any evidence
of pox marks having
survived an epidemic.
If you've been following the news
in St. Augustine they've recently
uncovered some human remains
underneath the parish church, what
was the parish church from 1572
into well more than a
century of this [inaudible].
And with the database, they're
doing DNA analysis on these bones.
They found 20 separate
individuals in this recent,
these recent excavations.
It is not outside of
the realm of possibility
that we could name
these people by name.
When we connect the database
where people were from,
who they were with the DNA evidence.
We're also going to
do a whole series
of digital reconstructions
for Florida.
This is magnificent map of
St. Augustine from 1764.
After the Seven Years' War
when Florida was transferred
to British rule and the
British controlled Florida
for 21 years after this.
And this was a map that was
commissioned by the crown basically
to plot all of the properties in
St. Augustine for compensation.
Because what happens in
1764 is every single person
in St. Augustine except for four
families, everybody else leaves.
The whole city's abandoned.
Most go to Cuba, some go to
Campeche, some go to Vera Cruz,
very few returned to Spain.
And the city's basically abandoned.
What this map, the originals
in the Naval Museum in Madrid,
what this map shows is
the size of each property,
who owned the property and the
building material that was used
to construct the residences
of those properties.
So on this one for example what we
can plot and it'll be much more,
look a lot better than this.
This is just an idea of
what we're trying to do.
All of those pink circles
represent properties in 1763
that we're owned by women.
These are all female property
owners from St. Augustine.
Here, well just the breakdown
of the building materials.
And Tabby which is a vernacular
concrete made from oyster shell,
coquina stone and wooden board.
And we see that most the buildings
were stone or cement constructions,
tabby stone constructions
in St. Augustine.
So the idea is to create this
digital recreation of St. Augustine
on the eve of abandonment.
All of these properties
are properties
that we've confirmed were owned
by free blacks in St. Augustine.
And we know where a lot of them
were from from the parish records.
We know that runaway slaves
were moving from as far north
as New York, Philadelphia, most
obviously from the Carolinas,
trying to make their
way to Spanish Florida
in the late 17th and 18th centuries.
For a lot of them we know their
ethnic backgrounds for the people
of African descent, those who were
Congolese, Carabali, Mandinga.
With maps instead of simply putting
maps on the center site we're going
to do a lot more animation
because again there's
so much incredible detail
that's lost to people
who aren't familiar with the maps.
So this is a map of the southeast,
the Gulf and Florida from 1544.
This is a map from right after
the Hernando de Sota expedition.
And there's Tuscaloosa.
All of these are Indian towns.
It's the only map I know
from the 16th century
that plots Native settlements
in North America.
I can't think of another one
that plots all these settlements.
And you get some text that's lost.
This text here says
[inaudible] which is
in present day New
Mexico, [inaudible].
From [inaudible] to this point there
are great herds of cattle, 1544?
Great herds of cattle?
And of course this is what
the Spanish are talking about.
For the Spanish the buffalo or
bison was simple a hairy cow.
And Native Americans do
exactly the same thing.
The horse in Mexico is not
some magical mystical creature.
It's a deer from Castile.
It looks like a deer.
It's a little different.
And the Spanish do the same thing.
This early interaction with
nouns is really fascinating.
So, all of these maps will have
transcriptions, translations,
explanations, annotations.
The technical team thinks that they
can build a something like an OCR
to read 16th century
Spanish paleography.
I have my doubts but then
Francisco looks at me and just says,
oh bless your heart, you
16th century dweller you
who we will be able to create
something that will be able
to read 16th century documents.
What we're thinking of it
initially as something to use
for museum visitors in Florida,
children who can take 16th
century letters from documents
from Florida and write their names.
What would you name look
like in 16th century Spanish?
And my evil plot is that eventually
all of these students are going
to start writing notes to each other
in classrooms using 16th
century paleography.
And I'll get hate mail
from teachers.
But then the sinister plot
that everyone will learn 16th
century Spanish will slowly
become realized.
And so that's the initial
plan with this.
Last summer I found the provisions
for the Archiniega expedition
for every single day for every
single person on that expedition.
So teachers who teach about
nutrition and could compare
for example the long term
implications of a diet
on a Spanish expedition
versus what English or French,
other expeditions look like
in terms of food stuffs.
And my wife actually plated these.
These are the actual amounts.
We took the amounts and plated
them except for the bread.
They did, we couldn't
fit that in a picture.
It's, it'd be a big garbage can
of your daily rations of hardtack.
They ate a lot of hardtack.
But this was the monthly ration
for olive oil and vinegar.
Friday of course you got some rice.
And then garlic was
only for the elite.
They said we'll give you some garlic
but distribute it with great care.
In other words only the
important people get garlic.
Does this look like a lot of wine?
>> No.
>> Does it now?
This was the daily wine ration
for every single person,
every single day.
Now of course they have to careful
with water and water spoiling
and this is what they're drinking.
And this is what you would get
for your daily ration of wine.
We're going to do all kinds of
visuals associated with this.
The site hasn't been designed but
this is kind of the general idea
of what we want it to be able to do
with the different areas of interest
in terms of the research.
The tutorials for people to
use it and the infographics,
the list of collaborators
and the advisory board
that we'll put together.
And the last thing I want to show
you is one of the ideas that we'd
like to do is populate the site
with a series of short videos.
These will be videos
about men and women
of different ethnic
backgrounds who lived
in Florida between 1513 and 1821.
Mainly stories about people who
are not particularly well known.
And so we did one and I want to
show that to you as an example
of the kinds of productions that
we will use to populate the site.
And this is a story that's
really actually if I come back
to this image here, this is a
story that centers around this map.
It's a map that dates to about 1605.
And it was a map that was, the
name of it was simply this is
where we need to move the fort.
The plan, King Philip III's
plan was get rid of the garrison
in St. Augustine and move everyone
closer to present day Miami.
And next to that fort on the
map is just a couple of words.
It says Vocas de Miguel Mora,
the mouths of Miguel Mora.
And I never knew who
Miguel Mora was.
And it bothered me for
years and years and years.
And then last summer I found him.
Not him exactly because he
lived in the 16th century.
But I found his story.
And why this region
ended up with his name.
And so we decided to tell
this story of Miguel Mora
which tells a little bit the
early history of Spanish Florida
and the story of Miguel
Mora himself.
[ Music ]
In the year 1605 an anonymous
mapmaker drafted a rather crude map
of the Florida peninsula.
Of the maps many curious features.
Perhaps the most striking is a name
that appears along the
southeastern coastline next
to purposed new Spanish fortress.
It reads Vocas de Miguel Mora,
the mouths of Miguel Mora.
The fort was never built but for
the next two centuries mariners
and mapmakers continued to
refer to the area by his name.
But who was Miguel Mora?
The story takes us back
40 years to the year 1565.
On March 15 of that year Pedro
Menendez de Aviles signed a private
contract or [inaudible] with Spain's
King Philip II outlining the terms
of a new conquest expedition
to Florida.
An experienced mariner,
merchant and military commander,
Menendez quickly began to recruit
colonists for his new venture.
While many of them came
from Northern Spain,
Menendez's forces included
men and women from other parts
of the Spanish peninsula as well
as Portugal, Flanders, Greece,
North Africa, France and Italy.
Almost 2,000 people joined the
expedition including sailors
and soldiers, artisans and
craftsmen, slaves and free blacks
and more than two dozen women.
One of the recruits was a young man
from [inaudible] in Southern Spain.
His name was Miguel Mora.
But just 11 days after
Menendez signed his contract,
King Philip II learned that a
French garrison had been established
in La Florida under the
command of Renee de Laudonniere.
Indeed Laudonniere's men had built
a fortress along the southern banks
of the River May, present
day St. John's River.
They call it Fort Caroline.
Even more alarming for the
Spanish crown were rumors
that a large French fleet was
about to set sail for Florida.
Menendez's colonization
efforts would have to wait.
The French settlement would
have to be destroyed first.
And men like Miguel Mora
would have to fight for it.
On June 29, 1565 Menendez's fleet
departed from Southern Spain.
Ten weeks later on September 8
Menendez stepped ashore 40 miles
south of the French Fort Caroline.
There he established
his first settlement
which he named St. Augustine.
A week later Menendez assembled a
force of 500 men to march overland
to attack the French fort.
It was a bold decision.
A fierce storm, perhaps a
hurricane battered Menendez's men
as they made their way north
through marshes and swamps.
Led by two Florida Indians the
Spanish troops reached Fort Caroline
in the early morning hours
of September 20, 1565.
Among the first Spaniards
to lead the assault
on Fort Caroline was Miguel Mora.
The Spanish victory
was swift and decisive.
And soon thereafter Menendez
began his ambitious enterprise
to colonize the American Southeast.
For Miguel Mora, his
Florida adventure was
about to take an unexpected turn.
In 1566 during one of his voyages
along the Florida coast Miguel
Mora's ship wrecked
in a terrible storm.
He and several survivors
were taken captive
by the Tekesta Indians
near present day Miami.
Mora spent 10 months in captivity.
>> There I was, naked, no
stockings and fearful for my life.
Worried that I would be
sacrificed by those Indians.
Dying of hunger and a captive
for a period of ten months.
Miguel Mora.
>> J. Michael Francis: After 10
months in captivity Mora and several
of his companions managed to escape.
He then joined Spanish expeditions
to [inaudible] and Carlos.
Before returning once
more to Tekesta,
the site of his 10 month captivity.
In 1568 the Spanish abandoned the
Takesta settlement along with many
of the other early garrisons.
Miguel Mora sailed to
Cuba and then to Spain.
He would never return to Florida.
Yet for more than two centuries
after his departure the shoals
and mouths near present day
Biscayne Bay carried his name.
The name of a Spanish soldier
in captive whose Florida experiences
have long since been forgotten.
[ Music ]
So this fall we're going
to launch our center
for Colonial Florida
digital history.
We're still playing with the name.
And the hope is that 5 years
from now, 10 years from now,
15 years from now we won't
have national history textbooks
that begin the whole story of
colonization of the Americas
and begin with Jamestown.
But instead cover this more
than one century period
that has been largely overlooked
in the national narrative.
And with that I thank you
for coming and I'm happy
to answer any questions
if you have any.
Thank you.
[ Audience Applause ]
Yes?
>> So in Florida do
they teach the history?
>> J. Michael Francis:
In fourth grade.
Now there are some teachers
in high school who find ways
to weave Florida history into
classes in language arts,
social studies in general
or world history.
But for the most part the
history, the Florida history
that students get in Florida is the
history they get in fourth grade.
And so, you know, and
it's not just in Florida.
I gave a talk a few years
ago at Spain's equivalent
of the National Geographic Society.
So an audience, a well-informed
audience in fact
and after the talk a
gentleman came up to me
and said thank you so
much for that talk.
I had no idea that Florida
was a Spanish colony.
So maybe there are
other ways, you know,
we can get people interested
in this early history.
You know, we'll do, we'll have
to do a lot of reconstructions.
Because of course the, for example
the Franciscan Mission Trail
in Florida predates the
California Mission Trail
by more than a century.
But the buildings themselves
are not there.
So the only way to do those kinds
of reconstructions is digitally.
And we, there's been
some phenomenal,
there's ongoing archeological work
in Georgia and South Carolina,
in Alabama, places that were
part of these early expeditions
and settlements and missions.
You know, the Jesuit mission
at Chesapeake Bay, you know,
these are things that I
think the best way to present
that material now is through
digital media and not, I mean,
people have been writing
these stories.
They're not really
new to historians.
That we've known about the missions
and about this early history
for well over a century of
people writing about it.
Popularly it's not well known.
And we hope that this will be
a way that through animations
and infographics and video
that people get onto the site
and then find it a little bit
like Alice in Wonderland's world.
And get into the rabbit
hole and dig deeper
and deeper and deeper and deeper.
And that's the plan.
So we'll have transcriptions
and, you know,
learn more about Miguel Mora or the
Franco Spanish struggle for Florida.
So it will be a combination
of things that we'll assign
to different PIs, experts
in at certain archeological
sites for example.
Other people interested
in prosopography, we'll
get them involved.
We'd love to do a section on
Spain and the American Revolution
in Florida where there
were English colonies,
East Florida and West Florida.
So there this 13 colony
business is in fact not accurate.
And a lot of loyalists of course
flee to East and West Florida.
So we'd like to have
those elements in there
with again all kinds of visuals.
And podcasting, we're going to do
some podcasting for this as well.
Yes?
>> Why [inaudible]
missions survive in Florida
like they did in California?
>> J. Michael Francis: Well
because they built the missions
from material that didn't
survive over the test of time.
They were waddle and dob
constructions with thatch roofs.
And then of course the
main reason why so many
of the missions don't exist were
they were destroyed by the English
and their allies as they came in
from the Carolinas and Georgia.
The early 17th century, late 17th
and early 18th centuries
those missions were sites
where of massive slave
raiding expeditions
from English settlements
to the North.
So they were absolutely devastating.
And so when the Spanish
left Florida in 1764
when they returned 21 years later
the missions don't come with them.
That's it, that whole mission
trail that existed starting
from the earliest established
mission which was 1587.
Just outside of St. Augustine.
What is now the Fountain of
Youth Archeological Park.
And the mission grounds
that are right next to it.
That is the oldest
established Franciscan mission
in the continental United States.
Places like Cumberland Island
had Franciscan missions.
So the whole story really
goes up the Atlantic seaboard
and into North Carolina
and what is now Tennessee.
And we think this is a good way to
weave all those narratives together.
And eventually weave it
into a Jamestown narrative.
Yes?
>> I'm very impressed with
the quality of the visuals
for example the last video.
Are you working with I don't
know like the art department or?
>> J. Michael Francis:
Francisco [inaudible].
His team, his team.
But, and the thing to remember
he was almost embarrassed
to send me that.
He said this is, this
is not what we can do.
When we really get going
and we have the resources
which we're building right now.
And so this was something they
did in what, how many days?
>> Five days.
>> J. Michael Francis: Five days.
>> Do you have animators
and artists and [inaudible].
>> J. Michael Francis: So they're
going to do that element to it.
They will be involved.
And they have, we have all these
partners who are coming into works
in Spain and Seville,
Cordoba, [inaudible], Madrid,
museums and other institutions.
Because this is a project that
doesn't work with one person.
You know, it's a big, it's a
massive team collaborative endeavor.
And Tampa Bay History Center has
just donated the rights to use all
of their colonial maps which
include some manuscript maps
from their collection,
the Tom Touchton collection
which is fabulous.
And so what we'll do is just
simply add animation to those maps
to make them more accessible.
Transcription, translation,
in some cases we'll animate
the maps themselves, you know,
the Drake attack on St.
Augustine is perfect for that.
The [inaudible] map is ideal
for something like that.
>> Will you [inaudible] digitize
those maps or [inaudible]?
>> J. Michael Francis: Yea,
we've digitized a number of them.
So the Tampa Bay History
Center, those are all digitized
in very high resolution tiffs.
So we'll have all of those.
We are working with some
archives, I can't really say
until we get the MOUs
in place for those.
But our team then would go in
and redigitize their collection.
And in exchange for redigitizing the
collection they'll let us use those
maps on the site at no cost.
Which is wonderful.
It's a great deal for them and
it's also a good deal for us.
You know, it's saddens me, you know,
when you see these incredible maps
and then you show them
say to a Florida teacher
and they say I've never
seen that map before.
I've never seen that one.
So they're making up maps
from the Colonial period
when they don't have to.
And many of them don't even bother
to look at the incredible repository
of maps here from, you know,
low resolution jpegs to tiffs
that they can just download.
And so, you know, we need
to somehow get that word
out a little bit better
that this material is here
and there's a lot of it.
And for Florida there
are millions and millions
and millions of pages of documents.
I mean, we're just
scratching the surface.
Yes?
>> You know, I was sort of struck
by the, by where non-Spaniards
of the expedition came from.
And I get a sense or a
hint that's an indication
of Spain's global position because
it seems to, a lot of it seems
to coincide with the
Holy Roman Emperor.
>> J. Michael Francis: Yes.
>> And I, the empire.
And I don't remember how
many Spanish kings were
in effect also Holy Roman Emperors.
J. Michael Francis: Well in
this period it's just one.
It's just Carlos Jesus.
Charles I and then Charles
IV Holy Roman Emperor.
And so from, Spain of course is
present in Italy, is, you know,
Italian merchants have been
setting up, moving their merchandise
from the Indian Ocean and Asia into
Spanish ports like [inaudible].
So in [inaudible] for example in the
16th century there's a large Greek
and Italian community of Florentines
and Genoese and Venetians
and Greeks living in
[inaudible] at that time.
So that, the world
of these mariners,
so many of these non-Spaniards
were people in the maritime world.
And they're circulating in
ways that we'd love to plot.
You know, we want to start to see
the movement of Flemish sea captains
who then become commissioned by the
Spanish crown to send provisions
and captain ships to different
parts of the Americas.
And so we want to build that
database of those people.
And in fact do some geoplotting
and plot the movements
of people over time.
I've read and I don't know if this
is true but certainly a number
of historians have repeated it and
I'm just as guilty of repeating it.
But the word is that
Pedro Menendez Aviles
who founded St. Augustine crossed
the Atlantic Ocean 50 times.
Now this is, it's hard to fathom.
How many people really have
crossed the Atlantic 50 times
in an airplane?
Let alone in 16th century ships.
He once sailed from St.
Augustine to the Canary Islands
in a small chalupa and
made that trip in 18 days.
So if we could plot them over time
and Francisco's team
would do a timeline,
you could plot an individual's
life and that movement.
And that's one of the things that
we want to incorporate into this.
Because I think anybody who works on
Colonial Latin American history one
of the first things that is so
striking is how much people moved.
People who were in Italy, in
Flanders, in different parts
of Spain, in New Spain, in
Peru, Northern South America
and had networks of people in
the movement of that information.
And lots of people have
written about this.
We'd like to try to find ways
to visualize that movement
so that it becomes very clear
to those who look at it.
And say wow, I didn't realize
there was this kind of movement.
And plot Menendez's
movement over his life.
So.
[ Pause ]
Wonderful.
Thank you.
Yes.
>> Thank you Michael.
I'm sorry I missed part
of the [inaudible].
I'm sure this was fascinating
[inaudible] Spanish embassies.
I'd like to offer support
[inaudible] should you need our
assistance [inaudible].
And even enlarge it to other states
because I understand this
is restrained to Florida.
>> J. Michael Francis: Well
it's beginning with Florida.
What we hope is that this could
be an example for a different way
to do digital history
and digital humanities.
And that other places would say
yeah, we want to do something
like this for Texas,
California, New Spain, Cuba.
You know the prosopography
it's one of the problems
with doing prosopography
is it's enormously,
enormously time consuming.
And it's not something you'd
really have a doctoral student do
because unless you wanted
that doctoral student
to spend 15 years doing
that project.
But if it were in smaller
parts and we could farm
out those smaller pieces
then that could work.
I would love to see the kind of
prosopography that we've done
for Florida for other
parts of Spanish America.
And right now it's
really quite limited.
And especially if you were to
compare it to the work they've done
in England which is incredible,
the prosopography for
Anglo Saxon England.
They're all sorts of incredible
sites on prosopography in England
because they've spent so
much time working on that.
And we just don't have the
equivalent for Spanish America yet.
>> I was going to say
when you say Florida,
what's your [inaudible] definition.
I understand West Florida ran
all the way to the Mississippi.
>> J. Michael Francis: Yes and of
course West Florida doesn't exist
until after the British arrive.
So Florida in the 16th century, I'm
taking the very loose definition
of what the Spanish
refer to as [inaudible]
which extended all the way
up the Atlantic seaboard.
You could make a case
that it included even
Newfoundland even though in many
of the maps they start to
refer to that area once you get
up into New England as the
Province of Cod [inaudible].
And you see the, this is
the land of [inaudible]
where they would cod fish.
But the Spanish saw that all as
part of the provinces of Florida
and it extended into the
interior until you arrived
at some unknown place
that eventually marked
what became New Spain.
>> I was going to say
when you mentioned cod,
the fisheries attracted
Spanish fishermen
from an early, early period.
>> J. Michael Francis:
Oh absolutely.
>> It was the cod.
>> J. Michael Francis:
Yea, absolutely.
In fact it would not
be at all surprising
if there were cod [inaudible]
and French cod fishermen before
Columbus fishing off those
grand banks.
But, you know, we don't
have the documents for it.
They were certainly fishing there
in the late 15th century
without a doubt.
And we have the documentation for
that cod fishing in the 1490s.
So probably before then
they were cod fishing there.
So yea, so that would be the
definition in the 16th century.
And then that definition, those
boundaries change over time.
And so you could do a timeline
for Florida that would mark that.
You know, you could mark
those geographical divisions.
>> I have an announcement.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.